there's a lot of talk in the new age
mage about the tao of the ancestors
or tao well what does the dao of the
ancestors
mean except that you are
the rearranged genetic component of your
particular genetic
stream and your grandfather your great
uncle your grandmother your great aunt
had ways of doing things pitting peaches
planting beans trimming flank steak
that's the bow of the ancestors that
there's a way to do
things and that when you do things
that way that is the appropriate way for
you to do it and you can tell it's the
appropriate way
because there is very little energy loss
that's what the dow is it is
appropriate activity
[Music]
well i think you know people have the
notion about
uh tribal people that they
that their life is very hard in some
environments in some situations it is
but people try everywhere to to create
leisure for themselves and to have an
opportunity for
aesthetic expression in psychedelic
societies
everything is art i'm thinking
particularly of for instance the shapibo
in their classic expression the shapibo
or
an amazonian tribe they cover
every utilitarian object with design
everything is is an expression
of the images of the internal world
and language and puns and this sort of
thing become
very important life
when you have nothing life
is easy easily transformed into art
because there's a howness about
everything
how you make a fire how you cast a pot
how you cook a monkey everything
is uh a paradigmatic activity
meaning everything is traditional
everything has been done millions of
times before in the way that your people
do it and so the individual is seen
almost like just the cutting edge of the
ancestral
energy and they even have the concept of
what they call the way of the ancestors
and so you'll be doing something like
sharpening a stick and someone will come
up to you and say
don't do it that way we do it this way
this is the way of the ancestors then
they show you how to do it
and sure enough it is easier
to do it that way probably because
this is the morphogenetic field of the
houndness
and i think ralph mentioned this morning
the confluence
of yoga alchemy
and shamanism in the taoist
tradition and i think it's worth
stressing that because to my mind taoism
is the most refined ideal of human
existence it is open-ended it always
yields to a good laugh it's not dogmatic
it's rooted in nature it's
uh sees the world as shells of
energy that can be manipulated and
cultivated and i really see
taoism as something broader
than the nature religion that arose in
southern china post
pre-confucius and so forth i see it as
the kind of natural way of being in the
world
that tribal tribally alive
societies settle into and it's what
we're trying
to recreate
appropriate activity that alone
would create a world informing
revolution
when i say that we must change our minds
the physical accompaniment
to changing our minds is that we will
begin to behave appropriately
bury our [ __ ] manage our resources
lower our voices
it's simply awareness
awareness and awareness of awareness
and this is what these societies have
that we have lost
and i think it's because the male ego is
a wart
on human perfection and everybody has
one it's not a put down of men the male
ego
is a part of the repertoire of every
human personality
in the modern world but it is
unnecessary
divisive and uh
and out of dow and this reconnection
with the tao with the flow with the
invisible
the spirits the energies of sky and
water and earth
the psychedelics impel us into
recognizing these things
but it's our own intent that can allow
us to bring these things
back into the world and apply them
so for me that was the lesson of
so-called
primitive people
now i think the taoist thing i'm coming
more and more
to it to see that it's its
open-endedness
its insistence on humor
uh not grinding a bunch of dogmatic
knives
and and now i'm talking about the
cultural ideal of daoism
taoism became secularized and you know
played power politics at
various times in the history of china
just like the other chinese religions
but its ideal remained the
psychedelic ideal i think and it's
basically a dropped
out a dropped out idea
it isn't that you should return to the
court
and take up the council of the king and
try to save his ass
it's that you know someone else can take
care of that
but these taoist immortals became
strange people i mean they were
fleetingly glimpsed
from the road running naked in the woods
as
people passed to and fro and knowledge
i have said this before made the
analogy between understanding and
gravity
that you know as something becomes
gravitationally more and more dense
it eventually is a so dense that light
can't leave it
no information can leave it it's said to
be a black hole
it has curved space around itself and no
information can leave it i think as you
advance on the path
toward enlightenment it becomes harder
and harder
for people to understand you and when
you finally achieve
enlightenment you can't there's nothing
you can't say anything at all
and anything you say is must be
misunderstood
that's the proof that you're enlightened
you know if you're a perfect black hole
you must be incomprehensible no
information must leave you
so if you understood anything i said
tonight it's a perfect
proof that i'm far from now
there's something which has been called
the dao of the ancestors
what that means i think is simply that
for each one of us
there is a way to do the things we must
do
that is the most energy efficient way to
do it
and i'm talking about opening a door
picking up a
fork the best way to do it is
to follow the creo that is the dao of
the ancestors to recognize that you are
a genetic
expression a partial genetic expression
of a gene pool
which has received genetic expression at
each generation in your family for
thousands and thousands of generations
and that you are just the latest
recipient
reception of this gene pool then you
release the ego
and you act with this awareness these
are
psychedelically induced states of being
that i think make it easier to live in
the world
and how many of them are there who knows
for instance under the influence of
psilocyman in the amazon
i noticed what i am completely convinced
is an
atrophied human ability
it's a very simple ability but we have
lost
it it's the ability to
know how to walk from point a to point b
not following the shortest distance but
following automatically the the
path of least resistance so that you
don't go
down into valleys and then climb hills
you automatically stay on ridges even
though you take more circuited
paths to your goal and i could feel this
sense working
it was just like a part of the dashboard
that had previously been covered up was
uncovered
here was a human sense which we don't
particularly need because we've
erected linear cities where
the most the path of least resistance
usually is a straight line but you can
imagine
people in rugged country this is a sense
which would confer
great survival adaptability and be
tremendously
important
something so extraordinary is happening
on this planet i mean you know for
hundreds of millions of years biology
flowed across the surface and species
advanced and retreated and
sensory organs were refined and
redefined and so forth and so on
but about 35 50
000 years ago language
broke loose and language is
the sheer will of information itself
to transform itself i mean we are
uh our medium is meat
but we are made of information
you know and that information could be
fed into a computer crystallized into a
virus
what we are is a long message
that is being typed out in proteins by
thousands of ribosomes coordinated over
time
we are sort of like a phonograph record
and when you're
young you know certain enzyme systems
certain genes
are turned on and then you pass into
midlife
other genes are turned on certain genes
are turned off
it's like a melody theme and variation
being brought back the theme being
enriched and worked and then finally
the whole thing builds to a crescendo
and then one by one the jeans are
turned off and the audience tugs on its
overcoats
and cabs are hailed and
people go home for the evening but that
that's what you are you're a
story a piece of code being run
in the great computer of of the world
but nothing lasts you know
not your friends not your enemies
nothing lasts and we deny this
and yet that's the great psychedelic
truth and if you can face it in every
moment and
live it you will have a very very
complete
experience of existence you will ride
the dao
towards the concrescence and be able to
live in the light of its anticipation
and this i believe makes for
a healthy life full of lots of laughs
[Music]
i mean what are we to make of ourselves
whither mankind
are we to be ultimately viewed as a
cosmic
accident the the perils of
unfocused intelligence or can we
reflect the inner dream the inner image
of
wholeness that inspires us and makes
us more than animals and raises us up
as a simulacrum of the goddess
that's what i would hope for and
thought cognition planning
caring emotion communication
intentionality focus
and authenticity are the domains
that we have to be in in order to carry
this
off you wanted challenge some of you
have made
fortunes that was no challenge you
wanted a challenge
save the planet there's a challenge
that's what everybody who came before
did they participated sufficiently at
least to pass the buck
to us can we participate
sufficiently to pass the buck to our
grandchildren
or are we just going to go down as the
lamest
generation in the life of the planet
i can't believe it i know too many of
these people i love too many of these
people
we just need to do our best
as the grateful dead say you know just a
little bit harder
just a little bit more you can't go back
and you can't stand still if the thunder
don't get you then the lightning
will so forward
into the future with a high heart
and reasonable hope that we can make
this planet into a living reflection of
the inner dream
[Music]
so if you understood anything i said
tonight it's a perfect proof that i'm
far from now
[Music]
but thank you for coming anyway